[Music]
when you think of movie duos you
probably think of iconic best friends or
police partners
but the most acclaimed movie duo of all
time is a jailed serial killer and the
fbi trainee agent who interviews him for
help on a new case
you use heavier skin cream
and sometimes you wear outlandite
but not today in addition to being only
the seventh best actor best actress
winner featured in the same film
the american film institute named dr
hannibal lecter played by anthony
hopkins
the number one movie villain of all time
and agent clary starling played by jody
foster as the number one movie heroine
of all time
so join us as we take a look back at the
entire cycle of five hannibal elector
films and
two television shows one for dr lecter
and one for agent starling
all told only once did foster and
hopkins start together in this
ever-evolving franchise but boy did they
leave a mark
though their characters will forever be
linked as of now they cannot even appear
in the same property together
dr hannibal lecter and fbi agent clary
starling's origins came from a series of
books by thomas harris
all of harris's first five novels have
been turned into films starting with
1977's fictionalized attempted terrorist
attack at the super bowl
black sunday agent starling appeared in
two of harris's books the silence of the
lambs and hannibal and dr lecter appears
in four
although surprisingly the cannibal never
took the head of the table in harris's
novels or films until
after the massive success of the film
adaptation of the silence of the lambs
dr lechter's introduction was in the
book red dragon
similar to the silence of the lambs and
red dragon dr lecter is a jailed serial
killer whom an fbi agent interviews
while on the track of a different serial
killer
the tooth fairy who's still at large
although there were many fan theories as
to which real life figure inspired the
character of dr lecter
harris mostly put that to rest in the
introduction to the 25th anniversary
edition of the silence of the lambs
here is his inspiration for the highly
cultured cannibal came from his
journalist days working for the waco
tribune herald
when he visited a mexican prison to
profile an american inmate who had
attempted a prison escape
the subject was shot by a police officer
and saved by the prison surgeon whom
harris had given the fictional name of
dr
salazar dr salazar's method of speech
was direct and full of puns and cultural
proactivities which fascinated harris
only upon leaving did harris learn that
the surgeon himself was
also an inmate serving a life sentence
for murder
the man whom harris describes as dr
salazar is reportedly inspired by
alfredo balai trevinho who was
not a cannibal but harris was drawn to
him because of how well-read he was and
the fact that he came from a prestigious
and educated family
he also liked wordplay and was open to
discussing his observed details into the
psychology of the other inmates
these are all elements that harris
instilled in his fictional lecter
attributes that make him
such a famous character charming and
refined yet a monster
in turning the surgeon into a
psychiatrist harris was able to use his
creation as a serial killer profiler
while also being behind bars as a serial
killer
five for ten strongly built about 180
pounds
blonde eyes pale blue he'd be about 35
now he said he lived in philadelphia but
may have lied
that's all i can remember mom but if i
think of any more i will let you know
and senator just one more thing
love your suit redragon was the first
book adaptation made into the 1986 film
manhunter where dr lecter was played by
brian cox
in the book and film lecter assists the
fbi profiler who caught him
agent will graham played by william
peterson while graham attempts to piece
together the methods of a serial killer
that lecter has
actually corresponded with through
personal ads
i want you to help me dr lecter yes
i thought director michael mann said
that throughout production producer dino
de laurentiis desired an increase in
lector screen time but mann
resisted saying on the movie's
commentary track i wanted the audience
to almost not quite get enough of him
though reviews of man hunter were mixed
at the time and it drastically
underperformed at the box office
it became a highly acclaimed cult film
and man's template of keeping lecter
as secondary character was replicated in
the next film adaptation
good morning dr lecter my name is
clarice starling
can i speak with you the silence of the
lambs is one of only three films to win
all five of the major academy awards for
best picture
best director best screenplay best
actress and best
actor but even though his presence hangs
over the entirety of the film
hopkins is only on screen for 16 minutes
of the movie's total run time
though hopkins played the doctor three
times the role was almost never his
gene hackman partnered with orion
pictures to purchase the rights to
harris's book in 1989
with eyes to not only star as lecter but
also to direct the film
but after playing such a dark role in
mississippi burning the actor wanted to
take a reprieve from such material
and with his desire to star in it gone
so too was his desire to direct the film
instead directing duties went to
jonathan demi who had just directed
orion's michelle pfeiffer fbi informant
comedy married to the mob
jody foster had actually attempted to
purchase the rights to harris's book
herself
but was beaten to the punch by hackman
with the rights gone foster could only
lobby for a role that meant so much to
her on a personal level
when john hickley jr attempted to
assassinate ronald reagan in 1981
he admitted to wanting to impress jody
foster and carry out what robert de niro
wasn't able to do in taxi driver
because of this attention foster was
given fbi security while attending yale
so part of what drew her to the role was
the intelligence and dignity in the fbi
that she had witnessed firsthand
the thing that i really love about
clarice starling is that this may be one
of the first times i've seen a female
hero
that's not a female steroid version of
arnold schwarzenegger
this wasn't a woman running around in
her underwear with a machine gun
clarice is very competent and she's very
human she combats the villain with her
emotionality
intuition her frailty and vulnerability
i don't think there's ever been a female
hero like that
for as menacing and bewitching as
hopkins is the silence of the lambs is
starling's story
foster plays an fbi trainee who is given
the undesirable task
of getting lecter to sign papers to
commit to a psychological profile
what lecter would rather do is give a
psychological profile on another
still-at-large serial killer
buffalo bill played by ted levine i love
the relationship between lecter and
clarice
i think she has a respect for him
because she sees him as a human being
and because she's not judgmental that
doesn't mean that she condones his
behavior or that she doesn't fear him
but she wants to know him the one thing
she has in common with lecter is dignity
because man hunter struggled to earn
back only half of its budget
dino and his wife martha delaurentis who
owned the rights to the hannibal lecter
character
had given the rights to the sequel for
free by doing so they chose to let orion
make the film and if it did well then
suddenly they'd have a major asset
after silence of the lambs dominated the
oscars and grossed
million dollars at the worldwide box
office the character rights to hannibal
lecter became a huge
asset you might say it aged finer than
the best chianti
it would become a negotiating factor for
the next three decades plus
it was the de laurentiis who would fly
down to miami on a yearly basis to check
on harris's status of writing a sequel
to the silence of the lambs
to cash in on their new company
cornerstone the events in hannibal the
book were set
one decade after the silence of the
lambs and by the time the movie
was released it had been exactly a
decade between films
hannibal finally put hannibal lecter at
the forefront of the entire narrative
this time after a raid goes awry agent
starling is at a career low point
and lured into finding lector's
whereabouts before one of his previous
victims
is able to enact an elaborate plot of
revenge
harris's new novel was the first book
that dethroned harry potter from the top
of the bestseller list
but reactions were incredibly mixed
including from three of the lamb's oscar
winners
prior to reading the manuscript foster
hopkins demi and screenwriter ted talley
all desired to return for the sequel
but foster tally and demi balked at the
direction harris's book went
alright cover your ears for 15 seconds
if you care about 20 year old novel
spoilers
by the end of hannibal the novel
hannibal brainwashes clarisse who
partakes in cannibalism with him then
they become lovers and escape to
argentina
and of novel spoilers doctor we don't
have any more time for any of this now
the ending of harris's novel changed
with the first screenplay to a slightly
less salacious ending between the two
characters
but foster still passed ultimately
julianne moore replaced foster and
ridley scott replaced demi hopkins
however responded to the guardian by
saying
just give me my plane ticket and i'll
show up note hopkins also received 11
million dollars to return
pause shout out to actor frankie faizon
who is the only actor to appear in
all of the four non-prequel hannibal
lecter movies
hi i'm barney he played a saint louis
police lieutenant and man hunter but
also appeared in the next three films as
barney a prison guard in both silence of
the lambs and red dragon
and it's barney who sells the doctor
liked her memorabilia to open hannibal
he thought she was charming and amusing
so clary starling and hannibal lecter
became
friendly well insider kind of formal
structure
yes and he was fond of her
yes does that make faison the original
fanable
thanks so much bonnie both hannibal the
book and film leaned into the curious
connection between hannibal lecter and
clarice starling
and though the film earned 350 million
dollars worldwide it was as divisive as
the book
not just for how their relationship was
rendered but also much of the violence
that
lambs alluded to without directly
showing that was more directly shown in
hannibal making it a
acquired taste
following hannibal a different
adaptation of red dragon was put into
immediate production
this time starring hopkins and opening
the film with hannibal lecter's exploits
instead of through agent will graham's
newly accepted case
i think he meant to use the bold cutter
to enter the house but he didn't
the final appearance from hopkins as
hannibal the cannibal earned 206 million
at the global box office
and had better reviews than hannibal
after three successive lecter hits de
laurentiis attempted a hopkins list
prequel from harris's final lecter novel
hannibal rising
with gaspard uliel in the origins of the
cannibal role
hannibal rising received dismal reviews
and returned lecter to the same space as
his first film appearance
making back half the budget hannibal
rising would also be the final worldwide
release from the famed italian producer
who died in 2010.
his wife martha still retains the rights
to lecter and served as an executive
producer on the hannibal television
series
because martha delaurentis owned the
rights to lecter and mgm retained the
screenwrites for clarice starling
only certain characters from harris's
novels could appear
on the nbc series mads mikkelsen played
dr lechter
hugh dancy played fbi profiler will
graham and lawrence fishburn played his
superior jack crawford
the series saw graham attempting to
solve a serial killer case in minnesota
which is taking a toll on his psyche
so crawford sends graham to see a
forensic psychiatrist
secret serial killer dr lecter the
doctor takes a
keen interest in graham's ability to
visualize the methodology of the killers
he studies
my thoughts are often not tasty no mine
passionate fans who dub themselves
fanables would have to attempt to save
the series during each season
with ratings overall for the show too
low to renew
but the fandom remains passionate and
launched campaign after campaign for the
series to continue
but after three seasons and 39 episodes
the series was cancelled
those same issues to writes to specific
characters make it so that the new cbs
show clarisse
cannot even mention hannibal lecter by
name even though the series takes place
weeks after the events depicted in the
silence of the lambs
catherine martin buffalo bills captive
and bill's dog precious however
can be mentioned so too will return the
west virginia senator in the suit
ruth martin and clarice's best friend at
the academy ardelia mapp
it's been more than 30 years since
clarice and hannibal teamed up on screen
and more than 20 years since clarice and
hannibal have shared a scene
meaning their final interaction will be
this dinner time conversation
i love the dress beautiful what do you
love about the pairing of hannibal
lecter and clarice starling
sound off in the comments below
you